[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud
proud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them the morning [__] strikes
again that's right there's important
issues out there in the world but there
is a very important issue that we need
to stay on top of every single day we
need to stay vigilant against it you
think there are a bunch of religious
people fighting each other across the
body of water wait until these religious
people start fighting us here the right
wi is really broken up this morning oh
my God they're fighting each other
remember I said yesterday we got a
steadfast we got to stay together the
pro-democracy Coalition for
Humanity that's our number one goal as
the pro democracy coalition to promote
hum Humanity the rightwing has severed
themselves
they're actually divided they're
dividing up they don't know what
narrative to catch where to catch it and
how to throw it good [__] them uh they
always spend their lies and their lies
always come back to bite them and it is
clear that the Republicans understand
now why why it was so important to
Democrats to keep the government open
why it was so important why it is so
important to I don't know do the work
that governments
do
as as the right-wingers try to figure
out which
government whether it's the Israeli
government or oh boy I can't figure out
which
one it is well I'm here to tell maglites
let me let me give you let me give you a
little bit of
insight into who you are I don't know if
you know this or not I don't know maybe
you do maybe you don't I showed you a
clip yesterday of a woman in Iowa who
claimed Donald Trump was sent by God her
God apparently was sent by her God to
save
America what in the [__] do you think is
happening over in the Middle East you
dumb sons of [__] maanga doesn't
understand that they MAA in the
situation that's happening in Israel
right now they are M they are the
terrorist they don't understand it
that's why part of the right is actually
supporting Hamas because right-wingers
are
typically inherently
anti-semitic now they get a little
bit they get a little bit iffy because
they definitely want Jewish people to
have their own state so they got their
own place to go to you know what I mean
you know what I'm talking
about that that kind of light loved
anti-Semitism right you know I I'm not a
Nazi I just work with Nazis you know
what I mean that type of [__] not really
a Nazi I just you know they help my
cause like Ben Shapiro that [__]
idiot that's right I'm gonna call him
out Ben
Shapiro that Jewish man who [__]
started a Nazi Rag and now he's trying
to figure out why right- Wingers are
pissed off at him I wonder what it could
be B
but we need to drive these wedges they
need to keep going and honestly as long
as Joe Biden the president United States
does what he's always done for the last
two years really for his entire career
if you want to know the God's onest
truth and you know I'm not a fan
of propping up Joe Biden or pretending
like Joe Biden is the best thing since
sliced bread but Joe Biden gets up every
morning puts his [__] shoes on and
does his
job and that's a president that we need
I don't give a [__] if it's Joe Biden or
a ham sandwich like the guy said
yesterday I'd vote for Joe Biden if he
was [__] dead before I'd vote for
Donald Trump and the perfect example is
what is happening in Israel right now if
you're not aware if you're if you're
still out there and you're you don't
have enough brain cells to rub together
let me give you a clear idea of who's
giving money to Hamas it is Iran who is
giving money to Hamas and they are
funded by Putin you dumb [__]
and if you're upset Ben Shapiro if
you're so upset that Hamas is crossing a
border and committing domestic terrorism
violence against innocent women and
children Across The Sovereign border
regardless of what your views of the
two-state solution are I don't give a
[__] it's terrorism from a religious
group who are a bunch of terrorists
funded by Putin then you should be
[__] pissed and you should be excited
that Joe Biden and America is defending
ukrainians you dumb
[__] these narratives are so
[__] contrived and so [__]
backwards the only reason why Ben
Shapiro isn't isn't on the side of Putin
and Hamas in Israel is because he's
Jewish that's right that's the reason
his religion and that's the problem
really in that region of the world is
religion I don't give a [__] what you
say you can come at me you give me all
kind religion I care which one it is I
don't give a [__] if it's Judaism if
it's Islam if it's [__] Christianity
they are used to [__] for fear porn
to make people violent and to kill and
to exterminate other [__] I
don't care what religion in history it
is a thing and when the right-wing
catches in any religion any of
them particularly in this country
Christianity when we have white
Christian running around this country
deluding the the St the stupid in this
country like the lady I showed you
yesterday who claimed that Trump was
sent here by [__] God and then and
then we have [__] in the media
inviting these religious zealots on
their TV shows to normalize them because
they want someone else besides Trump to
win well how the [__] did that go For
You Joe Scarboro in
2016 huh when when when in this country
are we gonna call trash trash and Joe
Scarboro in that show on the morning in
MSNBC is getting trashier by the [__]
minute a lot of people get mad when I
come after MSNBC or the left I don't
give a [__] I don't care it's bad what
Joe Scarboro did this morning was
[__] despicable he invited a goddamn
Nazi on his [__] show in normalized
him acted like they weren't going to
talk about campaign in the politics and
let meatball run his [__] mouth about
politics in the
campaign Joe Scarboro you need to get a
hold on your
show and you need to get a hold on your
[__] brain cells that you got left
and realize you don't get to control
what the [__] we're g to do Joe you
don't get to control it that's one thing
the media that's one thing the right
gets a right about the media if you want
to know the God's honest truth is the
media really tries to manipulate their
audiences right they really try hard
they [__] try hard that's why I try
to just tell you the [__] God's
honest truth the real raw truth and
nothing but the [__] truth and if I
find out it's not the truth then I'll
[__] back up I'll back up and I'll
tell you it was a [__]
lie it's
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous that we
have to act like the media isn't for
profit in this country and isn't plating
to their
ratings and isn't trying to control
messaging well [__] that [__] it's our
country they're the [__] press
they're the ones who are supposed to be
seeking the truth it's their job and if
they won't do it then we will [__]
them oh but Tony they have to be fair
they have to have all the presidential
candidates on what presidential
candidate Ronda santis is out of [__]
money he spent almost $20
million he ain't got a [__] dime left
he's about to lose all his goddamn
support and if you really believe the
polls which you shouldn't Ronda hasn't
ever even showed up in a
poll so what presidential candidate what
what which one you mean like
RFK who [__] fumbled the ball
yesterday when he announced that he's
trying to get manga manga supporters to
his Camp
huh when the hell when the hell is is
normal average people going to wake up
in this country and say enough is enough
of this [__] I don't need to [__]
have anyone on the TV or in the Elite
Class to tell me what the [__] do and
think whether it's whether it's MSNBC
CNN [__] tyt or anyone else out there
telling you all kinds of [__] and I
know I know a lot of people are going to
say well Tony there's some good people
on MSNBC and that may be the [__]
truth but
godamn godamn he's supposed to have
Ronda santis on to give us some kind of
insight about [__] Israel and Hamas
when Ronda santz is the governor of
[__] Florida who gives a good goddamn
what Ronda santis thinks about what
happened in Israel and with Hamas huh
who gives a
[__] you talk about you talk about
[__] torturing people Ronda santis
knows some things about torturing
people maybe that's what [__] Joe
Scarboro should ask that son of a [__]
well during war what is it like to
torture [__] huh Ronda santis
what is it like to torture [__]
in a prison H war criminals in a prison
what's it like like to torture him
Ron as you sit back and you do that
weird ass Android laugh of
yours what the [__] was the purpose of
acting like Ronda santis was on their
show this morning in a non-political
interview and then to continue continue
to talk about [__] politics and the
campaign and let him Yammer on about
it I tell you what it is Joe Scarboro is
trying to control the messaging folks
that's right that's what he's trying to
do he's trying to seep into the brains
of the audience to normalize No Labels I
showed you that last [__] week with
Joe
Mansion when Joe Mansion got pissed off
that Joe Biden dropped [__] drug
prices because he's in the pocket of big
Pharma oh [__] Joe mansion's got to get
on Joe scarber and pimp no
labels to get back at Joe Biden to put
Joe Biden in his place and Joe Scarboro
capitulates to that nonsense that
[__] lie that somehow No Labels has
any kind of [__] any any kind of
political movement in this country no
one likes that [__] frankly it's the
same thing as RFK announcing his
independent
campaign a lot of people think that
again they're just trying to [__]
fool everyone else and I'm going to show
you this RFK fumble
today and and [__] Republicans are
freaking the [__] out
oh my God they're freaking the [__]
out terrified and
mortified that the the the the monster
they created in the antix
Warrior that RFK Jr is that somehow that
dumb son of a [__] who believes any
conspiracy theory that comes his way
wouldn't believe the [__] that he
could actually win to be president when
are you GNA have him on Joe huh are you
g to have Joe Joe scar are you going to
have [__] RFK Jr on your show talk
about all kinds of antiva all kinds of
[__] just lies conspiracy
theories both sides the [__] out of it
bring him on let him let him talk let
him say anything without a [__]
single bit of
pushback I'm telling you folks you can
[__] hate me all you want I don't
give a [__] I'm gonna call we need to
stay on top of this [__] and normalizing
Ronda santis is not going to help this
country
I don't give a [__] who's doing it if
it's Joe scarber or someone on Fox News
I'm G to [__] call it
out and this morning Joe Scarboro bold
face lied to his [__]
audience oh well this is going to be a
non-political interview we're here to
ask Ron theis the governor of Florida
that has nothing to do with [__]
Israel or the policies in Israel or any
kind of foreign policy about about about
Israel even though we're not going to
talk about a presidential campaign get
the [__] out of here with that nonsense
just straight up li I listen to it go
back and laun the whole [__] thing
I'm gonna show you a couple clips of it
this morning of Joe Scarboro
capitulating to this [__] and I
guarant godamn to you Joe Scarboro just
like he took a call from No Labels he
told you that [__] he told you he took a
call from No Labels to get Joe mansion
on to to give a shot across the bow of
the American people because Joe Biden
lowered prescription drug
prices you think it just so happens that
Joe Mansion showed up on Joe scarber's
Morning Joe with cadd K those three
[__] [__] sitting around a table
talking about no
labels you think it just appeared out of
nowhere or do you think Joe Mansion who
is in the pocket of big Pharma [__]
went on that show to make sure to to to
show that Joe Biden has a
weakness huh what do you think it
is just like joose Garo had Ronda santis
on this
morning you normalize Nazis you're going
to normalize fascism you dumb [__]
[__] Joe you stupid bastard who do you
think Ronda santis
is who do you think any of these [__]
Republicans are [__] I'm going to show
you a goddamn video remember the video
we showed of that [__] Nazi [__]
down in Franklin Tennessee who had Nazis
protect Nazis real literal [__] Nazis
they call themselves Nazis
they're [__]
Nazis protecting her running for mayor
she's an alderman what a what a [__]
despicable piece of [__] that that
[__] woman is let me let me tell you
something I'm going to show you a video
These Nazis that are protecting her are
threatening PE citizens lives not
opponents not political opponents
denters this is what Nazis do this is
what Ronda santis is he's he [__]
wants to get rid of any
descent they're terrified of descent and
the reason why they're terrified of
descent because of people like me who
won't shut the [__] up who won't quit
yelling who won't point out their
[__]
fascism because as long as we keep doing
it they'll be exposed and as long as
they're exposed we all you fascists are
bound to lose as Woody Guthrie
says it's enough of this [__]
and for the for Joe Scarboro to have
[__] Ronda santis on and lie to the
audience Lie To America you piece of
[__]
garbage Joe Scarboro you need to get out
and you need to [__] apologize right
now
[__] and anyone who's not just
furiously pissed off about what [__]
Joe Scarboro did this morning you're not
paying
attention you're not [__] paying
attention you're distracted by a bunch
of [__] by right-wingers trying to
divide us up because of Israel on
Hamas trying to spin their stupid
[__] narratives posting videos from
2020 Mario hey you dumb [__] I'm
looking at you I've been in your spaces
before you son of a [__] you're posting
videos on Twitter of of in Syria of
rockets launched in Syria claiming that
it's that it's rockets in
Israel to Gaslight our Gaslight us hey
why you're sitting and Eric Trump
retweets it hey why you [__]
Rich ass [__] are sitting in
your goddamn penth houses acting like
you're citizen journalist posting [__]
on Twitter as if you're some kind of
newsman why don't you do this why don't
you check out the [__] facts first
you [__]
losers huh why don't you [__] do
that cuz the fact is in this country
manga is H
they back Putin guess who [__] backs
Hamas
Putin you dumb
[__] wake up use your goddamn
brain cells and I'm talking to you
[__] MAA because I know this shit's
going to get clipped and I know it's
going to end up as a YouTube short and
it's going to end up in your [__]
feed and you're going to be all [__]
butt hurt all cope everywhere with your
[__] comments down in this son of a
[__] and don't give a [__] frankly I
hope I get in your feed and I hope I
stay in your [__]
feed I hope YouTube keeps pumping these
goddamn videos right down your goddamn
throat because I'm sick and tired of
your [__] nonsense and your goddamn
lies this country is sick of this
[__] and if you don't think if you don't
think trying to normalize Ronda santz a
[__] Nazi hey you dumb son of a
[__] he's got Nazis literal Nazis on
overpasses and in front of Disney World
hailing him as if he's Florida's
Hitler you got it he's a [__] Nazi
him and his goddamn Zealot
wife and you're gonna bring him on a
national [__] cable TV show claim
that it's non
political and then try to normalize him
because you're scared Trump's gonna be
the
nominee I'm not are you scared Trump's
gonna be I'm not scared that Trump's
going to be the nominee we're GNA whip
his [__] ass next year him and all
his [__] MAA allies every last
[__] one of them we're g to Trout
them [__] in this election and
the reason why is because the
pro-democracy Coalition has had enough
of this [__] we're sick and tired of
hearing about these [__] we're
sick and tired of watching May
candidates and Franklin
be escorted by Nazis we're sick and
tired of Nazis standing on overpasses
telling us who the [__] we should
hate telling us why diversity Equity
inclusion is bad telling us why
liberalism is weak [__] you it's time to
get mad it's time to get pissed
yesterday today tomorrow next week next
month and next goddamn year and stay
pissed the whole time don't let up
they're not going to [__] let up
I guar godamn tee you
that some people think I'm [__] crazy
but I'm telling you I'm telling you
they're coming for you and they're
coming for your [__]
family you think they're going to stop
at the lgbtq community you think they're
going to stop there you think they're
going to stop at taking women's just
their Healthcare away huh Tommy
tuberville is dug in he doesn't want
women in the [__]
military [__] he wants wh he he doesn't
want women in jobs probably that white
[__] Christian nationalist a goddamn
Nazi that's right every [__] one of
them if you got an R next to your name
you're a [__] Nazi if you go and you
have dinner at a table with a [__]
Nazi if there's a Nazi sitting at that
table with 10 other people having dinner
yucking it up there's 11 [__] Nazis
at that table and you better well damn
better better know that
[__] we see it right now in the [__]
narrative in the [__] and the lies
that we see around Israel and Hamas
they won't stop they're not going to
stop it's going to continue this way and
I don't know how much evidence I have to
give to prove but I am gonna get inside
the [__] bubble of MAA and I'm gonna
[__] bang it apart [__] him it's
enough of this
[__] woman standing in
Iowa claiming that Trump is sent by
God to save a
America believing it with her whole
heart of
hearts she's not just saying that [__]
she believes that
[__] and when you convince people that
[__] you will convince them to do
atrocities just like the Palestinians
believe that Hamas is their
protector don't you know that don't you
[__] see
that you don't you don't think that
there's people out in our population
believing that the Insurgency of MAA is
there to protect them huh because of
religion
huh it's real it's
here and it ain't going
nowhere the only thing we can use is use
democracy that's it that's our
tool otherwise we'll end up in a
situation like they are in
Israel doubt me you [__] doubt me
[__] even Marjorie Taylor green and
other maanga are calling for a Civil War
and red States and blue
States we want to
divorce where do you think they're
looking to
huh where do you think they're looking
to to their example of how they want it
to
be just doubt me you go ahead I'm going
to show you video
today
I'm going to show you video
today of a candidate for mayor and I
know that seems insignificant folks but
listen if these Republican candidates
for
mayor can be just walking around with
Nazis and threatening people's lives on
social media with those Nazis I'm I'm
not kidding you this is a real
thing it's it's incredible that this
isn't National [__] story it's
incredible that this isn't all over the
[__] news what is happening down in
Franklin Tennessee with these nais and
what they're doing to average citizens
who are trying to ask their mayor
candidate questions about her
affiliation with a bunch of [__]
Nazis not only will she not answer she
uses
screenshots to intimidate those voters
and have her Nazi [__] supporters
threaten their lives it's a real thing
happening and we should be thankful for
Phil Williamson down a Nashville that
stays on top of that story because I'm
sure Phil is just I mean he's getting
death threats after death threat after
death threat from these [__] Nazis
and [__] I I might I may be next
by by giving a megaphone to Phil's story
which we should the Tennessee holler is
even John Oliver is giving a megaphone
to this story because because it's
important now John Oliver is doing it a
certain way to give it some comedic
backdrop cuz it is laughable when you
find out this story when people around
you find out this
story they will probably laugh at
it but this is what they want all around
the country not just in in in the
mayor's race and some [__] town in
Tennessee Ronda Sanz has not has not
denounce the [__] Nazis down in
Florida who say they are supporters of
him who are in front of Disney World and
on an overpass howling Hitler
folks they're not hiding that they're
Nazis I'm not speaking out of turn or
being hyperbolic they're carrying
swastikas on
flags doing the Hitler
salute those same [__] the same
groups of people are protecting maror
candidates in Tennessee soon they'll be
protecting Congress people they won't
just be protecting Governors they'll be
protecting Senators like Tommy
tuberville they'll be
protecting Congressman like Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren
bobert and they already did the proud
boys the one the one [__] Nazi in
Tennessee's got a proud boys tattoo
right on his [__] face I showed it to
you
one plus one is [__] two that's what
it is that's the fact you can spend it
however you want but the fact is
Republicans are [__]
Nazis and if you're still in the
Republican party and you don't think
you're Nazis the Nazis think you're
Nazis it's time to get
out time to
leave time to drop that [__] and I'm
going to stay on top of and I don't give
a [__] who it pisses off I don't care if
you're you're mad then I'm [__] mad I
don't care get mad
too rather you love me or you love to
[__] hate me come and watch this [__]
because you're going to need to know
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
follow on the podcast hit subscribe
right now go to the Tony Michaels
podcast follow everywhere subscribe on
the Tony Michaels
podcast the newest episode is always at
the top you can support the show there
through through Live support or
memberships but follow follow
follow Facebook twitch Twitter yeah I'm
not going to call it X I'm still going
to call it Twitter they they're making
me change the logos and [__] but I'm
still gonna draw call it Twitter I don't
give a [__] what Elon says he can kiss
my ass he's a Nazi too everyone stick
around Texas Paul it's Tuesday when we
come back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy pel's mail
do you feel exposed to a government that
doesn't share your patriotic values if
any of these describe you then you're in
luck hi I'm Paul goar and thanks to my
new product pardon blanket I've got you
covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after you're involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup part and blanket will
protect you too paron blanket is made of
a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
$999.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast
oh speaking of Na CH Shaz Max is back
that [__] Nazi that's right Shaz I
see you on Facebook you son of a [__]
PA us queers that's right we're queer
and we're here baby and we're proud
we're proud to be allies you [__]
frighten little animal you you little
[__] bigot get it straight keep
watching Chaz maybe you'll [__] learn
something a time or
two that's right that's what he that's
what he call
hey queers leave our children alone what
hey what do you someone needs to check
shaz's electronic devices quick and then
hurry who [__] said anything about
children Chaz you [__] weirdo why do
you people why why do you weird
[__] always go straight for the
children huh why why why do you got do
you got pictures on your cell phone on
your computer huh huh Chaz it makes me
wonder about people like you keep your
pride FL in your circus show in your
damn bedroom what the [__] are you
talking about I'm not in my goddamn
bedroom where are you in your mama's
basement you little keyboard Cowboy you
frightened little [__] huh why you don't
have to be scared of your sexuality Shaz
you really don't we will accept you we
will accept you if you just come out of
that closet that you're in in your mom's
basement and keep watching you little
[__] maybe I'll learn a thing or two
here
anyways I'm sorry I had to go after a
troll what do you want from me what do
you want from me see yeah see look he's
a Nazi see look vote vote Nazi santis 24
and 28 Shaz Shaz doesn't know that Ronda
sanz's career is completely [__] over
he doesn't know that because Ronda
santis won't won't [__] won't [__]
denounce Nazis in Florida that support
him that his career is
over and it's because of people like me
I'm not going to stop yelling and
screaming that they're [__] Nazis
because they are just like Texas Paul I
know he's not going to stop doing that
either Texas Paul how are you today my
friend doing good hot man [__] hot
I'm telling you I am just are you
burning up you got hot flashes angry
angry extremely angry oh did did I did I
did I raise the fire did I raise the
flame level over there is that what
you're saying oh man it's been ever
since Hamas declared war on Israel and
uh you know me i' for years I've spoken
out for the Palestinians for for years
man I have and and but October 6 that
stopped that stopped I don't do that
[__] anymore um but the takes that have
come out of the corporate media the
takes that have been coming out on on
social media have just been infuriating
dude I am just so freaking hot I get it
I'm not flaming people I'm not attacking
people for it you know people aren't
like us Tony we we follow this [__]
closely right every day the average
person that watches can't man they this
is not what they do you know they've got
other Li you know lives this is this is
unfortunately these are this is our
lives man this is what we do so people
your average person they just get a list
in their head you know this this
situation this is the good guy this is
the bad guy this is the good guy this is
the bad guy that's just the way it works
man and there's so many knee-jerk
reactions coming out that are just
[__] insane Tony and I just I get it
they're doing their normal reaction but
people need to be following what's going
on man it it's [__] hell I mean it's
anyways I don't mean to go off on Iran
sorry no no no I you know I I've
been I I don't know why I mik muted um
I've been thinking a lot about this
about you know what's going on in Israel
and you know why it pertains to us here
obviously our security relies on this
and the reason why is because Putin is
uh 100% backing Hamas whether you like
it or not Putin is giving money to Iran
and Iran is funding Hamas and and this
this conflict that we have is going to
last maybe a week or two it's not going
to last that long and the reason why is
because Gaza relies Gaza City and the
Gaza Strip relies on Israel to let water
and fuel through to have electricity and
to I don't know have water seems like
pretty essential thing to have water um
and and they're going to cut that Supply
off and when that Supply gets cut off
it's it's going to get dire in Gaza City
um as they bomb and continue to level
buildings and residential areas because
MOS are cowards and they hide in
residential buildings and they hide in
hospitals um but you know I I got to
thinking about it and thinking about
what's happening in our country because
we've never we haven't really seen an
Insurgency in our country um since the
Civil War there really hasn't been a
real Insurgency they've tried several
times the KKK tried really hard uh the
America First Nazis tried really hard
during the second second world war they
really try Nazis have tried hard and
hard and hard to have insurgencies in
this country but manga is a very
successful type of Insurgency right now
U there there are there are different
types of uh people in the maanga
movement right like in in U Gaza there
are just the regular old people who are
brainwashed by manga that manga is going
to defend you a lot of this happens in
rural areas right and they use they use
the fear of religion
um to stoke that propaganda and to stoke
those lies right so so they they end up
believing [__] that isn't true like the
woman I showed yesterday who believe
Trump was sent here by God to save
America and some some [__]
propagandist in the maganga arm some
militant in the maganga arm has
convinced this lady of that right just
like in Gaza City some of these people
are convinced that Hamas is their
protector and the reason why isn't
because they
they're inherently evil it's because
they're lied to they're propagated with
lies and and and and they're andas is
using those people to move their their
their religious their theological
movement their political movement their
fascist movement to kill and and have
genocide of the Jewish people right and
and it's the same [__] [__] here
that right-wingers are using and
propagating lies to get the [__]
sheep the manga sheep to believe these
[__] lies so that they can continue
to propagate and continue these
political movements to eradicate Women's
Healthcare to eradicate women from the
military to to eradicate our fellow
countrymen in the lgbtq community in the
trans Community they want to absolutely
eradicate them they want to get them out
of society they don't want to see them
um who do you think's next it's Jewish
people here who are next because in this
country in this country in this country
Maga is Hamas that's what they are just
like Hamas uses propaganda and lies to
convince these people because what they
do is they say oh look look Israel is
[__] bombing hospitals well the
reason why they're bombing hospitals Red
inair is because Hamas militants are
hiding there they're targeting those
areas because they're organizing in
those areas but you know again the
Palestinian people are deluded to
believe that Hamas is their Defender and
they're not they're not their Defender
they're there to use them to prop up
their [__] their hate it's what it is
and there's a lot of people here Tony
that are still supporting you know that
are like oh well that you know we the
Israelis are the bad guys here and this
and they're trying to both sides this
you can't both sides of this folks you
can't you know you you've got one
situation where and the and the
corporate media is the worst because all
they are is oh poor Gaza poor Gaza poor
Gaza this is the truth this is the truth
October 7th in the middle of the night
October 7th Hamas declared war on Israel
they attacked Israel with no warning
they went into town to town to town they
murdered civilians they they they killed
children in their beds they cut baby's
heads off Tony they're terrorist they're
[__] terrorist I mean just just what
it is we're just getting yeah the the
Israelis have finally taking these towns
back and they're allowing reporters into
the towns and it's just horrific what
they're finding they were raping people
they are raping PE this is going on they
are raping people they took hostages to
use as human Shields that's one side on
the other side the IDF hours after this
attack started started broadcasting on
the Arab channels in Gaza Hamas has
declared war this is a war we are at war
with Hamas Hamas chose the battlefield
of Gaza this is where they fight like
you talk about hiding in hospitals
hiding in whatnot the IDF said this area
is a safe Zone this area is a safe Zone
this is a route for civilians to escape
they they they laid out Escape Routes
for them they did not bomb those areas
they didn't they warned them in advance
where they could hide and be safe then
they started the attack on
Hamas and and they do they use it they
use what is called roof knocking um
which is a thing and a lot of people
don't like roof knocking but because
Hamas leaves to what roof knocking is is
they use drones uh to send rockets that
don't have warheads on them to shake the
buildings so that the people know what
the target is now does Hamas run too yes
but but it does break up their
organizational pattern and that's and
that's the best Israel can do in Gaza
City and if you don't know anything
about Gaza City it is a [__]
hellscape I mean it is Hell on Earth it
is one of the most heavily dens
populated places on Earth and it's one
of the most poor populated places on
Earth and I think I think the statistics
are over 40% are children in in in Gaza
City it is an open air prison is what it
is Israel even refers to as an open air
prison why is it an open air prison
because Egypt closed when when the
Palestinians were trying to escape
there's a war coming Israel has warned
them there's a war coming we've given
you advance this is 4 days later now
they've warned them there's a war coming
Egypt closed the Border would not they
don't want Palestinians in their country
jordanians don't want Palestinians in
their country syrians don't want
Palestinians in their country Lebanese
the Lebanese don't want them there it's
an open air prison because the Arabs
won't let them go so what did the
Israelis do they bombed The Crossing
into Israel and opened it up they
destroyed the the fences that Egypt put
up to block the Palestinians from
fleeing what has the mainstream media
said what has the Palestinian propaganda
said oh well the the uh uh yeah yeah
well wait a second I I want I want to
push back on you there because there is
a difference between Palestinian people
and Hamas Hamas are the actual militants
or the actual are the actual terrorists
they're the groups that's being funded
by Iran now there are Palestinians that
are not Hamas but I will tell you that a
lot of pales Ians have been
propagandized to believe that Hamas is
their protector and that that's that's
really the truth here the truth is is
that in war propaganda is a real thing
the German people in the 1930s believed
that Hitler was going to bring them
Prosperity he believe they believe that
[__] now they were being lied to and
they believe lies just like the lady I
showed you yesterday that stood in Iowa
saying that Trump was sent by God to
save America it's the same propaganda
it's the same same lies that that that
uneducated Palestinians are believing
about Hamas so I I do want I do want to
push back a little bit Palestinians AR
are not exactly Hamas they're not always
right I'm not arguing with that I I that
I will tell you that's why Hamas enjoys
80% support among the Palestinian people
you're right but that's not what's
happening what I'm saying is Egypt is
keeping the Palestinians in a war zone
Israel is bombing Crossings so that they
Escape well let's talk about Egypt and
Israel in the sea because really that's
what that's what Gaza is is is bordered
by is Egypt Israel and the Sea now on
the Sea on the sea front um they do have
uh the ability to fish now they were
bombing fishing boats this morning my
guess is those fishing boats are are on
excursions to get Munitions out out
further than what the the fishing boats
are allowed to to to be uh in a military
border um but it is and and
yeah fake fishing boats right right well
they there are real Palestinian fishing
boats that are fishing but Hamas the
terrorist the terrorist they use that
they use that aspect to
go further their advancement of
terrorism on Jewish people in Israel so
and they and they [__]
propagandized the the the Palestinians
by telling them see they're they're
bombing your fishing boats they're
bombing your fishing boats which are not
bombing a fishing boat it isn't really a
fishing boat it's a boat that is
designed to to to help commit more
terrorism and to appear to be a fishing
boat again it's the same [__] when
when maanga does this [__] here in this
country when when something happens and
they [__] lie to you like they're
lying about the6 billion dollar
humanitarian fund that's set up by in
Qatar where where a r Iranian oril was
sold to South Korea and not a single
nickel not a single nickel that $6
billion dollar had has been has been
used it's the same thing when the right
deludes manga in this country with a
bunch of [__] [__] like oh
Trump's innocent it's all Witch Hunt
against Trump all the evidence that
you're seeing that's not evidence oh
look Joe Biden's actually the criminal
we can't tie any kind of transactions to
him it's the same [__] [__] it's
the same [__] now does that mean
yeah and you can't both sides this [__]
though that's what I'm saying you cannot
both sides I'm not defending Israel's
you know all the way up to October
freaking six before this happened I
decried everything Israel ever did wrong
and spoke out for the Palestinian people
but they're attacking those fishing
boats Tony because somebody taught tamas
how to conduct amphibious Landings right
and they used those boats when they came
in the middle of the night and murdered
freaking civilians and babies and raped
people and kidnapped people they they
engaged in amphibious Landings using
those fishing boats so yeah they're
freaking destroying any boats that come
anywhere near you know any I mean they
are they're just it's a war Tony fre and
you can't both sides this right well
just like we shouldn't both Sid [__] in
this country I want to point something
out here because some people and and
this is kind of off topic here but it is
on top it because Shaz Maxi's the little
troll that I went after uh Shaz um some
people said that I shouldn't give him a
platform but people are treating him the
way they need to be treating him here's
Scott P Perkins shazm what's up with the
sandis eating boogers and Trump sexually
assaulting women see that's how you
handle them you don't you don't cast
them away so they can go somewhere else
and do their trolling you [__] hand
them their ass okay that's what you do
that's how you do it now rather rather
[__] Facebook will ban me or Scott
fine whatever whatever the [__] they
want to do that's how they want to do it
but that is how you handle a bunch of
[__] Nazis on the social media
platform thank you Scott um I just want
to point that out I just want to point
that out um so Tony clear I'm not
arguing with you you're making a great
[__] point an outstanding [__]
point yes Hamas has support because
these people are isolated and
propagandized continuously they blame
their lot in life on the
Israelis but it's every damn Arab
country in the re region just like the
Kurds Tony I've all I still I still
advocate for the Kurds they get [__] on
by every Arab country in the region
includ and you know turkey as well
you know I mean it's just it I I I
advocate for Armenia armenia's been [__]
on by every Arab country in the region
it's just the way it is with these
Palestinians so I can't go along with
the ride that this is all Israel's fault
it's not it's not it's just well again I
I there's no excuse for the type of
terrorism that Hamas has the atrocity
that they committed in Israel um there's
no excuse for that is Terrorism that's
what it is no matter no matter what
Israel did to invoke that it's the same
thing when they flew planes into
buildings on September 11th um it
doesn't matter what was provoked that's
[__] terrorism when when when a
right-winger in this country gets a gun
and goes into a grocery store and
[__] murders black people or murders
people of his Hispanic descent that's
[__] terrorism I don't give a [__]
what the motivation is I don't care what
they what what kind of excuse they use
to murder people it's inhumane it's
[__] terrorism and that's the way it
is period period now when when we're
talking about when we're talking about
the difference between Hamas and
Palestinian I wasn't saying you're wrong
I just want to make sure that we point
that out that this is fact this is real
[__] that is happening that that yes are
the Palestinians on the side of Hamas
yes they are they are on the side of
Hamas because they're being [__]
propagated by Hamas to to to use
Palestinians as their shield and they're
doing that now on the other side of
things has have has the Israeli
government with Benjamin Netanyahu
really swung harder right absolutely and
it's it's astonishing you know you don't
like to see it you don't want to see a
democracy step away from democracy um
some people are blaming that Benjamin
Netanyahu kind of took his eye off the
ball um with the judicial thing and he
he moved around some troops but I I
actually don't see any evidence I don't
see any evidence that that had anything
to do with this attack I don't think
Kamas is is capable enough um to launch
this attack because of that or um timing
it with the way the Ben and I'm not a
Benjamin Netanyahu fan folks [__] they
timed it on the holiday they timed it on
the holiday of sim chat to to catch the
Israelis with their pants down because
on simchat to you're not allowed to work
it's a celebratory holiday that's why
they're having these festivals you've
heard Daniel Dan Congressman Daniel
Goldman was there um some of these yeah
he was in he was in Tel Aviv um um he
was actually on Morning Joe this
morning he was on Morning Joe this
morning and right before Ron de santis
Joe Scarboro capitulated to that [__]
Nazi yeah Shaz that's what I said your
candidate he's a Nazi that's what you
like about him the best that's what you
like about him the best jez is you for
not une equivocating Tony thank you for
not une for for for not being ambivalent
about that he's a [__] Nazi is he's a
[__] Nazi Tony for saying it just the
way it needs to be said I I always
appreciate you that for that well like I
said I've been calling them Nazis for
years people for years have been saying
ah Tony you're you know you're you're
going a little far I'm telling you in
the years to come you will know you will
know why I did that and you will know
why I propagated that oh speaking of
propaganda um boy everyone's saying this
is Joe Biden's fault you know they want
to they want to blame this on um oh my
God they want to say this as Joe Biden
let me show you a video here I am so of
uh of someone who is trying to who's
been trying to meddling in the Middle
East for a while now this is this this
is definitely not during the Trump
Administration wink um when Jared
Kushner was trying to negotiate get his
uh his payday in the Middle East watch
this I am so grateful for the
opportunity to work on important matters
such as Middle East peace and
reinvigorating America's Innovative
Spirit every day I come to work with
enthusiasm and excitement for what can
be Krishner also his background in real
estate not exactly as a hedge fund
magnate or peace broker in the Middle
East it's becoming a little less clear
what he actually worked hard at because
after he left the White House he went
out and raised $3.1 billion dollar
that's billion with a B for a private
Equity Fund and as you pointed out he's
not a private Equity guy he's a real
estate guy so where did this money come
from some of it we know from filing some
of we know from press reports what we
know for a fact is he raised the $3.1
billion what we also know for a fact is
that only about $30 million of it
actually came from investors in the
United States all the rest of it is
foreign money you know what Republicans
in the last few days have been talking
about $6 billion but it seems like they
forgot about this three billion doll
that Jared Kushner got it just it feels
like to me that they just completely
forgot about it it you that they just
completely forgot about this I mean they
really want to blame they really want to
blame the $6 billion dollar that has
Iran hasn't gotten their hands on H that
was one of the things that Joe Scarboro
let Ronda santis get away with this
morning Ronda santis said well uh money
is fungible you know so the $6 million
that's sitting in account that's just
that's just $6 million that now Iran can
transfer somewhere else no it's not Ron
because they haven't spent a single dime
of it nor will Iran spend a single dime
of it Iran is never going to withdraw
that $6 billion dollar for humanitarian
Aid because Iran is a bunch of [__]
terrorist the people who run that
country are [__] terrorists and not
only that they are funded by Putin to
fund terrorism all around the world and
the reason why is because people like
groups like Hamas like the terrorists in
Iran and Putin need chaos they have to
have chaos they cannot function without
chaos and the reason why is because they
have to keep their [__] populations
full of fear porn is what they have to
do and the best way to keep their
populations full of fear porn is to
continue to create chaos and another
reason another reason Tony they haven't
spent that a penny of that $6 billion
dollars is because it's Gat kept by the
United States Treasury and if they just
leave it there to gather gather interest
and wait they're hoping a republican
Administration will come in and the
Republicans will just give them full
free access to that money instead of
gatekeeping it for humanitarian reasons
so why not just sit on it and let it sit
because then you know they're hoping in
a few years with their propaganda
campaign they're going to get a you know
a trump-like presidency where they'll
just get all6 billion dollars to spend
however the hell they want and another
thing that keeps getting forgotten is
where the $6 billion dollar came from it
came from Trump allowing the Iranians to
sell
oil6 billion came so you're so you're
saying you're saying this was all part
of Jared kushner's little piece in the
Middle East thing is that what you're
saying because they they they gave Iran
special dispensation there there you
know we had we were getting the entire
world to put sanctions on Iran and then
Trump and Jared Kushner went ahead and
gave them special dispensation to sell
oil you remember the [__] the
Republicans were trying to sell is oh
this is Biden treason because you know
and it turns out that they're spy gal
Luft was arranging Iranian oil Sals
sales to China
mean their little their little
whistleblower he was their guy making
deals for Iran to sell oil that's where
all that [__] came from that's where
the6 billion dollars that Iran hasn't
spent a penny of came from well you know
Republicans are in disarray and this
morning they don't know how to respond
to this and the reason why they don't
know how to respond is because they
can't find a leader it appears to me
that Donald Trump has handpicked Jim
Jordan as his little house Speaker
Lackey um that's what he did with Kevin
McCarthy and I believe that Donald Trump
believes that he's going to be able to
handpick his speaker that he wants to
shut down the government um and they're
gonna shut down the government I don't
give a [__] what you say it is Donald
Trump's mission to shut down the
government and we are going to be less
safe if we shut down the government that
is just just like we're less safe we're
not less ready but we're less safe
because Tommy tuber won't stop his
blockade in the Senate now should the
Senate move to change these rules that
is a possibility those procedures might
be in place but the House Republicans
can't even [__] pick a speaker here's
Steve scalise um because he's happen to
come out of his illness here to try to
uh uh run blockade against Trump and Jim
Jordan because that's what Trump really
wants Trump thought he had Kevin
McCarthy in his pocket and he found out
he didn't Kevin McCarthy was a traitor
taga because he wouldn't shut down our
government he wouldn't [__] the American
people in the end because he knew that
Republican party would take the blame
but here's Steve scalise trying to make
it seem like he's gonna run what's funny
is is even on Fox he's getting pushed
back because he won't tell the [__]
truth on a normal
process that day one as well when I'm
elected speaker well I understand but
the truth is is with all due respect
Congressman you're not answering any
questions do you endorse sending money
to Israel in an emergency package do you
endorse sending the $24 billion that
President Biden is asking to Ukraine are
you going to manage these bills lower
number as you asked me I just told you I
spoke with Ambassador durmer yesterday
about very specific things that Israel
needs some by the way are in the What's
called the esops bill State Foreign Ops
bill that we just passed out of the
house the defense Appropriations bill
that we just passed out of the house
that's real money in pieces of
legislation we passed out of the house
ready to go iron
M things that we've been talking and
obvious we need to talk about even more
specific things you want to get details
I'll get into details with you but
Congress can't do any of that while
we're not functioning without a speaker
oh Steve scales points out points out
what we've all been pointing out is that
Republicans can't govern and yes not
only is he a Nazi I think he's
self-proclaimed himself the David Duke
without the KKK baggage hasn't he he's
actually yeah he was speaking he was
speaking at David Duke conferences to
the K directly to the
KKK yeah that guy's a freaking Nazi man
he is and and and he's and you're right
he did he did Proclaim that himself that
he was David Duke without the without
the baggage he said that about what 15
years ago well he he said he said I'm
David Duke but I wasn't a grand
Dragon like all right dude that's kind
of weird that's kind of weird that's
kind of weird um now Donald Trump is
trying to H you know talk about this uh
Israel thing but he's having really he's
having a lot of trouble why you looking
that up can I flow a conspiracy theory
yeah go purely a conspiracy abolutely
let's do it yeah this was I think the
Republicans are helping Putin with
because you know this Hamas attack this
is does nothing but help
Putin nothing but help and it's and it's
it's trained and directed out of Iran
who is who are just thick as thieves
with Putin they're as tight as can be I
think it's
timed to be at this time where we have
our military
decapitated we have our our uh uh House
of Representatives where any spending
bills or reaction would come out of has
no leadership so they can't react they
can't bring bills to the floor uh you
know and and whip their caucuses and you
know I this was intentional to happen
now and I believe the Republicans are
complicit I believe they all timed this
that was Putin's birthday by the
way that's the little fact is been
October 6th that's are you [__]
[__] me nope they gave this to him
as a birthday gift that's the
conspiracy I that's my conspiracy theory
it was Putin's birthday and the
Republicans gave him this gift I said
October 6th I mean October 7th um but
yeah this was all a birthday gift to
Putin he needed another war on another
front that wasn't a direct conflict with
NATO and they gave it to him they gave
it to him at this time on
purpose you know decapitated the house
decapitated our military the Republicans
are in bed with Putin that's my
conspiracy theory let's see what Grandpa
poopy pants thinks about is Israel being
attacked and now it even pertains to
Israel what happened yesterday was
incredible I mean whoa so many what
yesterday was incredible you know this
guy he really needs to [__] figure
out vocabulary doesn't he like dude you
can have words that describe things that
aren't a huge incredible fantastic like
you can say it's despicable like there
are words that you can use um but
incredible is not really a word that I
would use to describe what happened in
Israel incredible is kind of it's not I
I wouldn't use that would you use that
word I wouldn't use that word incredible
I mean incredibly despicable maybe that
is uh the correct way to use it but you
know and then he goes on to talk about a
snake and people love it I'm not
[__] you people killed I don't know
you've been here but the number was much
bigger than they reported even this
morning ah the numbers are much bigger
of Texas Paul he can't focus on anything
but numbers and big numbers can he again
it's the same old stick out of this
[__] idiot's mouth it's a very big
number very very big number vicious too
vicious young children just slaughtered
it's terrible what's but it's incredible
you know that this is the snake and it's
people love it
God he's still doing the snake Texas B
now a lot of people are wondering why
Grandpa poopy pants doesn't seem to be
able to put two senten together the
other thing it doesn't seem like he can
do is talk about anything but [__]
whales and and and um and and windmills
you know he's got whales and windmills
on his [__] mind because he can't get
enough thoughts together but here's
another moment from this speech in New
Hampshire that I that I picked out and I
was like this [__] here listen
to this um for any MAA that get a hold
of this video watch this your [__]
your your mango musolini Jesus no
Administration in history no
Administration cared about the fishermen
and the lobster oh yeah not not one not
one president cares about workers never
in the history of ever ever had any
Administration cared about workers and
fisherman and lobsterman but let's
listen to what he believes about
lobsters Texas Paul he says it in the
next sentence R if you want to call it a
sentence I only did it because selfishly
I love that Lobster you know oh yeah
that's right Texas Paul [__] them
workers [__] them workers I love my
Lobster get out there and get me my
[__] Lobster you God damn pores get
out there and make sure my Lobster is on
my plate in my penthouse you pores I
don't give a [__] about the lobster man
I just want my Lobster that's literally
what he said and these people are like
Yay he he hates us he hates the average
person what the [__] how does people
listen hear that [__] I tell you it's
that psychological thing man people make
a list this is who I support this is who
I oppose and it doesn't [__] matter
what gets said or done or anything they
automatically go back to that carping
like a goddamn
seal he said it you know I mean it's
just it's [__] amazing the way human
beings work man it really is we we are
we are a a hell of a [__] species
watch this again Watch what he says
about it now he's claiming that no other
president has cared about Lobster
lobstermen or fishermen and he's saying
he was the same way when he was the
president like he's saying yeah I didn't
give a [__] about him either
listen I only did it because selfishly I
love that Lobster you
know I hated the lobster too and the
fisherman [__] them I just wanted the
lobster [__] the fisherman and the
lobsterman just as long as I get my
Lobster I don't give a [__] what the
[__] is wrong with this guy oh my God ID
hey you wantan a you want a useless
trivia factoid yeah go ahead yeah you
can actually you know I love history man
I love to go back and and history is
going back and reading people's letters
reading contracts reading things like
that one of the things that were put
into contracts for uh uh people that
worked in wealthy homes Butlers servants
whatnot I'm not talking about slaves I'm
talking about people that actually had
contracts to work is that they couldn't
be fed lobster more than twice a week it
was considered trash fish for the
longest time anybody of means would not
touch a lobster but it was dirt freaking
cheap and you could catch it easy so
they would feed it to the help it was
like an ocean roach is how they looked
at it that's how they looked at it like
they looked at it as an ocean Roach and
then and then the lobster industry
needed to sell more lobsters so what
they convinced rich people of is that
hey this is a delicacy from the coast
like this this is not a ocean roach this
is this is this is delicacy and and they
started selling it in different parts of
the country as delicacy because they
couldn't get it and you know when we
built [__] roads and [__] in this
country and we could mark it across the
country um I love your audience dude I
love your they're so well in friend of
me you would put it up there yeah fed it
to prisoners that's absolutely true up
in the Northeast where they would they
would literally feed Lobster to
prisoners because it was like you said
it was considered the roach of the sea I
mean it
was speaking speaking of [__] roaches
this guy on MSNBC this morning um this
is just one little clip that I'll show
you here of Joe Scarboro normal trying
to normalize Ronda santis this is
[__] despicable too I know what Joe
garell is trying to do I get I I see
what you're doing Joe you son of a [__]
I get what the MSNBC producers are
Morning Joe are trying to do trying to
normalize this [__] because
they're terrified that Trump's gonna be
the candidate I get it I understand what
you're trying to do but this guy this
guy is not something someone you want to
play with this is the same [__] you
[__] did in the media back in
2016 with Trump when you're trying to
normalize his dumbass and you're doing
the same thing with Ronda santz here
Ronda santz is a [__] Nazi period you
need anything other for saying it Tony
thank you for saying it but here's Ronda
santis in their non-political interview
literally Joe Scarboro starts the thing
with Ronda santis coming on he's like
this isn't going to be about the
campaign this isn't G to be about
politics this is about Israel and what
is happening with Israel and Hamas and
we're gonna have an expert on Israel as
if Ronda Sanz is a [__] expert on
Israel or something he's a [__]
Florida Governor for crying out loud
what the [__] does he have any interest
in in his public
position as someone who gives a [__]
about Israel other than he's trying to
beat Trump in the presidential primary
but watch this clip watch this stupid
[__] look going forward as Republicans
you know my argument's been very simple
if the election is about Joe Biden's
failures and our positive vision for the
future which it would be if I was the
candidate we will win if it's about what
uh piece of paper or document was left
at the toilet at maral Lago or all these
other things on January 6th if that's
what the election's about uh then it's
going to allow Biden to be in his
basement uh and they are going to be
able to do it again hey did you hear
that Chaz did you hear that you're
you're paring his propaganda you just
said while ago that Biden's gonna be in
a basement or some dumb [__] in the chat
oh man you're not you're not a [__]
shill at all you don't [__] uh uh
type in talking points on my show are
you working for Ronda sanz's campaign
did Ronda Sanz send you here to Facebook
to come to this show I almost bet he did
because because Ronda Santa campaign
knew that I was going to attack this
[__] this morning and I'm GNA
attack not just him but Joe Scarboro
right now you piece of [__] trash Joe
Scarboro doesn't even push back on the
fact that Ronda Sanz in a non-political
interview that that's supposed to not
have anything to do with the election
that it all only has to
do with what is happening and this
literally how Joe Scaro started off the
interview to light his audience and let
Ronda sanis go on and on and on about
his campaign and go on and on and on
about the election but let's continue
let's see how they [__] capitulate to
this
nazians what do you want to be talking
about you talk about a
toilet something being that that really
brings up an issue I wasn't gonna bring
up but let me ask you really quickly
because we're about to run out of time
uh should should Americans be concerned
are you concerned by the fact that
President Trump uh revealed War plans to
invade Iran military attacks against
Iran uh to people that didn't have have
classified
uh Joe
scarber [__] [__] or get off the pot
would you either ask this [__] a
question about Donald Trump committing
[__] possible treason and what he did
on January 6 and stealing documents this
[__] is running for president of
the United States and you're talking
about someone who's not supposed to be
in a political interview but he's all of
a sudden talking about the campaign so
now you want to make it about that and
you don't want to just I don't know say
what needs to be [__] said and asked
him the question Joe because the
agreement was is that you'd have Ronda
santis on that was the agreement that
you had with the campaign and you
wouldn't ask him about [__] about Trump
because you the the santis campaign Shaz
hey the the santis campaign doesn't want
to be caught [__] attacking Trump
because Trump is King mauga you stupid
[__] he's the Jesus he's the cult leader
and Ronda santis here cannot be appear
to be attacking the cult leader that's
why Ronda santis is like well all this
toilet stuff these these classified
documents and this treason stuff oh
that's all that's all [__] and Joe
let him say it listen classified ability
to see those
documents well look I think that's an
allegation it remains to be seen
obviously if it's proven that'd be a
different thing but I would just note
and I think this is why a lot of
Republicans are concerned about some of
these cases is that he was being
attacked for years as being in collusion
with Russia and that was not accurate uh
it is accurate it is accurate
[__] there's people who went to
prison for it Ronda santis you line sack
of [__] Nazi [__] keep going though
that was a false narrative that was
created not a false narrative it's a
false narrative from you [__]
not to tell the truth created and so I'd
be uh did you hear Joe scarrell there
did you hear him did you hear him Texas
Paul did you or was I talking let let me
back it up see if you can see if you can
see what Joe scarrell thinks of of Ronda
sanz's narra listen really close is that
he was being attacked for years as being
in collusion with Russia and that was
not accurate uh that was a that was a
false narrative that was created and so
I be right did you hear Joe he says
right right right just like he said with
Joe mansion with the No Labels [__]
that I pointed out last week these
[__]
scumbags sounded like Sling Blade
yeah right right the answer is no sir no
it was collusion there's people who went
to prison and Donald Trump pardoned them
for it and there's people still in
prison because Russians were giving
money to the Trump campaign there's a
dude in prison right now I don't know if
you know the T there's a dude in prison
right now that actually Trump gave him a
pardon from [__] he did in Iowa um and
he was also he was also uh on Mitch
McConnell's campaign he was also on ran
Paul's campaign he's a Ron Paul Lackey
he actually he's in prison right now for
facilitating russan money to put it in
the Trump campaign did you know that did
you [__] know that that's crazy [__]
that's crazy [__] that Russian collusion
[__] you know it's almost like there's
there's evidence out there that proves
what Ronda sanus is saying is
[__] it's
funny go ahead yeah do do you want me to
play the you you sent me the booger you
sent me the booger L you want me show
you the boogers uh we'll play this for
shz we'll play this for shz Shaz did you
know did you know that you that you're
supporting a Booger Eater Not only is he
a Nazi this guy [__] loves to eat
boogers audience prepare yourself this
is gross oh it's [__] fantastic he
don't eat it but he don't eat it but
watch oh he eats boogers watch him he'll
eat him I'll shall point out where he
eats him Governor hi uh you and Donald
Trump have gone back and forth in the
last last few days over who turned he
wiped him on his face there see that's
he's saving that one for later you know
what I mean he's saving that one for
later now now let's see what else he
let's see other then wait for it nice
slow-mo of it wipe the sweat cuz he
sweats like a wh in
church wiped it across his mouth smear
that booger
on they cut it off his next thing he
does is he makes a big lick on his upper
lip well yeah cuz he got to get that
he's got to get that booger that booger
sugar off
his off his limp oh man let's keep going
here let's see if he let's see if it
gets oh yeah oh oh yeah save that booger
for later put that right
here oh my God you know the best you
know the best part about it is that
maanga makes fun Ronda santis [__]
eating his boogers almost as much as we
do almost as much as we do they [__]
love to make fun of that sun [__]
eating his
boogers that's why I don't call him I
don't call him pudding fingers anymore I
don't call him to Satan I don't call him
you know any of the nicknames he's now
de booger de booger de booger that's
what hasag the booger the booger the
booger booger booger booger all right
speaking of uh Nazis who love boogers
let me show you this report from Phil
Williams um at at channel five Nashville
um this is [__] disturbing I showed
you this [__] last week of a meril
candidate let's see her name is uh that
that that Gabrielle Hansen she's a Nazi
and you know she's a Nazi because she
likes to hang out with Nazis and that's
just that's just the cold hard truth I
don't know how else to put it this that
[__] in Tennessee it is it is it is it
is and her stupid little Nazi [__] that
protect her but it gets it gets it gets
even more uh deep here because she's
using her Nazi little foot soldiers um
her SS as it were to intimidate just
voters not her opponent but voters watch
this report from from Phil Williams the
political controversy in Franklin now
may be a full-fledged Scandal thanks for
joining us I'm Rory Johnston and I'm
Hunter hogland Tonight Phil Williams has
uncovered new evidence that mink
controversial mayoral candidate
Gabrielle Hansen to a white supremacist
effort to harass her critics and Phil I
know you have been working hard all
weekend on this story what do you have
for us I I have the latest twist began
when when a woman who was one of
Gabrielle Hanson's most persistent
critics went to a campaign event Friday
night to confront the Franklin olderman
as you're about to see before the night
was up a white supremacist who was not
at the event would be using the
encounter to attack the
woman this flyer was put on our door and
it says you know come and meet Gabrielle
Hansen so we decided that we would go
and meet Gabrielle Hansen Peggy
kingsbery and her husband Paul have been
outspoken critics of Gabrielle Hansen
the controversial Franklin olderman okay
so I want to back it up here just for a
second that there that little the blonde
here right here in the middle that is
Gabriel Hansen you know Nazis don't
always look like Nazis do they Texas
Paul not always but this one does well
her her her husband looks like something
I'm going to show you a John olor clip
about husband here in a minute but let's
finish this here the controversial
Franklin Alderman now running for mayor
I'm walking towards the meting great
oops sorry about that are you yes yes
what would you like to talk about oh I
want to talk with the candidate not with
you so when they showed up at a meet and
greet in their own neighborhood a
handsome supporter named Valerie tried
to run
interference it seemed casual except for
the fact that this woman walked up and
immediately wanted to to intercept us
I'm part of the campaign I would love to
speak with you I'm sure you would but I
want to ask her about some issues
okay what issues would you like to talk
to her about I'll speak with her about
that who's her Gabrielle Hansen yes
Alderman Hansen yes Alderman Hansen do
you see what's going on here in Texas
Paul this [__] stupid ass nice
[__] with casseroles type attitude
you know what I mean you know it this
gives me a real whiff of moms for not
you
know Liberty right the look on her face
I'm pretending to smile but I [__]
hate you you can just see it in her you
can just see it all in her face I
pretended to smile but I [__] hate
you oh yeah and don't you know don't you
know this little this little Nazi here
because if you're protecting Nazis you
are one H don't you know this Nazi here
has the Bible and MC right on her
[__] bedside table this piece of [__]
let's keep going how she how she tries
to run run the fence for Gabrielle
Hansen here running from there in the
evening would only get more bizarre as
Peggy attempted to ask Hansen about the
white supremacist who had escorted her
and her husband to last week's
candidates Forum okay so um we I showed
this video last week and this was part
of it but this guy here this is this is
one of the nais and if you look on his
face right here that tattoo right there
that's in this shot it's not so clear
this is Gabriel Hansen's husband I'm
going to show you him in a in a in a
speedo with his dick tucked in here in a
little bit I'm not kidding you at a
pride parade I'm not [__] you that's
a thing it's a thing I'm gonna show it
to you it's funny as [__] um but this
guy right here he's got he's got this
proud boys tattoo on his face I wonder
if proud boys are Nazis or not it kind
of that kind of bre proud boys or paps
Blue Ribbon could be peanut butter oh
yeah that's the pr I think [__] [__] I
think [__] [__] sounds about like
about right uh a [__] [__] sandwich
here is what this is now again this is
Gabrielle Hansen's husband in this
really shitty Hawaiian shirt and then uh
with the proud boy tattoo this is a guy
who proclaims himself online on social
media as a literal Nazi that's his words
not [__] mine we watched that in the
video last week but let's continue but
is it true Tony is it true I mean that's
what I keep getting in my feed is you
know they this guy tells he's a [__]
Nazi but I get shot in the ass on my
left butt cheek from people to the left
of me on my left [__] flank that tell
me but is it true is it confirmed
[__] said it
himself right what do you mean is it
true he he thinks he's a Nazi he
believes he's a Nazi he likes Nazis he
is one okay that's how this [__]
works if you're Nazi you're a Nazi times
you just like Nazis and you don't know
that you're liking Nazis but in this
case they know they're liking Nazis but
it'll prove it out here just watch here
in this clip those same characters later
made derogatory posts on social media
about people perceived to be Hanson's
critics they posted a picture of Peggy
along with her home address the post
ended it's about time that her and her
kind were silenced and they were
threatening me the only connection I
would ever reason have any reason to
have with those that group of people
would be because of her they they
shouldn't even know my name they
shouldn't even know I exist did you
suspect that e either she or her
campaign was behind those harassing
messages I didn't know I didn't think
these threats were emanating directly
from Gabriel Hansen but I thought she
needed to know these people that you
seem to be connected with are
threatening my wife then is Valerie shot
video of The Exchange Peggy pressed
Hensen for answers are you aware that
your friends the white nationalists have
threatened
my no I don't they are not my friends oh
they're not her friends Texas Paul
they're not her friends oh jeez I guess
they're her business partners I don't
know what the [__] didn't he just arrive
with her husband at the event well you
know that's not EXA I mean you know
friends really well let's see what let's
see how she would Define them
are you aware that you're Associates or
the people who claim to be your friends
Associates what are they [__] what are
the Nazis then what are they if they're
not your friends and they're not yours
they seem pretty friendly Nazis don't
just flank someone here's the scene
Nazis don't just flank someone to walk
them into a building because they're
scared of their safety literally this is
the Nazis words because if you go back
and watch the interview that Phil
Williamson did with the actual Nazis who
were outside protecting her I mean maybe
they're hired security but who hires a
bunch of Nazis as their security I
wonder who it could be let's continue
ensen denied the white supremacists were
there to provide security for her as
they claimed saying she had her own
security it is true though these guys
did
threaten do you have that in writing you
can I absolutely do when we're done here
and I'm not recording I'll show it to
you watch
this
how would I send it
to you can show show it on here you show
her that's when they say Valerie snapped
a pick of the white supremacist post
that showed Peggy's email off to the
side that was so there it is so they
didn't do a screenshot Texas Paul they
did the old style screenshot where you
take one cell phone and you take a
picture of another cell phone you ever
seen these type of screenshots you can
point them out anywhere watch as it be
is pointed out on social media just just
minutes later holding it just like this
yes I heard Gabrielle say something like
can you get a still can you get a still
shot of that a short time later Peggy's
photo appeared in a white supremacist
post with the TA well well well one of
our critics must be scared it ended this
ain't your Revolution no more we're
taking over from here hell Victory okay
I don't know if you know what hell
Victory with the two SS lightning bolts
there means but that means they're Nazis
I don't know how else to say I don't
know what Texas Paul I mean maybe I'm
off my rocker here but hail Victory with
the two SS lightning bolts it feels like
to me it feels like to me threatening
this person's life when it says this
ain't your Revolution no more we'll take
over from here and it seems like that
this this one uh person who's a
gatekeeper for the Nazi Gabrielle Hansen
and I'm gonna call her a Nazi because
she is one that's what she is um took
the picture of the screen and then sent
it to the Nazis to post on telegram
isn't that what it seems like to you
that's what it seems like to me that's
exactly what happened yep well let's
watch we're taking over from here hell
Victory exactly what I held up was on
telegram with a new threat information
is there any other way that this group
could have grabbed that image absolutely
not I've not shown that specific image
to anyone but that night to Valerie so
it had to have come from either Miss
Hansen or someone associate with her
correct it's an experience that the
kingsb say has made them more cautious
but more determined what what has that
done for your comfort level we're not
comfortable with it but we do feel like
every citizen has a role in democracy
there is no reason my name and address
should be known to any Nazi in the
United States
anywhere can you even imagine this woman
sitting there saying in that sentence
right she probably probably three four
years ago she'd never dream she was
sitting on Channel 5 news in Nashville
having to say that sentence that no Nazi
anywhere in the United States should
know my name or who the [__] I am that's
crazy [__] and how weak and cowardly
these Republicans are these freaking
Nazis are cuz could you imagine the
response okay we know that that [__]
taking that picture forwarded that image
to these Nazis or put it up herself we
know that's how it got there that image
was created right there we know where it
came from could you imagine if we showed
up at these [__] houses and
took pictures of their houses posted
their addresses posted where they work
they' be crying they'd be crying oh my
God you're hurting my freedom of speech
oh you're just you're you're trying to
make me
we got to send the police to protect
them because these crazies are just they
intimidating us you know yeah I mean God
that would just be all now if you're if
you're wondering what party Gabriel
Hansen's in um watch the end here you'll
find out pretty
quickly and it's known because I got
involved in a political process I got
involved in
democracy I reached out to miss Henson
this afternoon to get her response but
just as we've seen time and time again
we never heard back all right we know
Gabriel Hansen a republican she's
running against Republican incumbent
mayor Ken Moore right have you heard or
is there any chance that Republican
leaders there are going to come out and
say enough's enough well you know
individual Republicans have spoken up
but nothing from party leadership party
hierarchy so we we'll see it just seems
that's because they like the Nazis I
don't know I don't I don't know how I
say Republicans like that Nazis support
them they like that Nazis go to drag
shows they like that Nazis protect their
candidates at at hearing they like that
Nazis get online and threaten denters
that's what they like that's what
Republicans like it's a feature of the
party now they're they're they're
Republican Nazis is what they are um and
I appreciate Phil Williams staying on
that story it's very important but I
also want to show uh Phil Williams
reporting showed up on John Oliver now
I'm going to get smacked on the wrist
for this in YouTube but I don't give a
[__] because this is worth it tene
holler posted this video on Twitter of
John Oliver's Show talking about um Phil
Williams the the reporter and that is
exposing Gabriel Hansen for being a Nazi
watch this this is great if you are a
politician in Tennessee Phil has his
foot on your God damn
neck His official News Channel 5 bio
features a quote from a Nashville
political strategist saying if the Press
calls call your PR person if Phil
Williams calls call your lawyer because
you are in trouble this is a bad bad man
you do not [__] around with Phil
Williams and it seems Gabriel Hansen is
currently in her finding out era when it
comes to her dealings with him because
Phil has uncovered so much weird new
context around her life remember her
[__] outrage over the local Pride
event well Phil discovered something
that a husband wants D that suggests a
hell of a double standard okay I got
Chaz in Shaz in theuh chat here he said
save our kids again Chaz we need to
check your electronic devices it makes
me suspicious when you keep saying this
in the chat but I want you to pay
attention here buddy I want you to pay
attention to the Nazi I want you to pay
attention to Gabriel Hansen and her
husband before they moved to Tennessee
uh what happened here so take a listen
here shance take a listen to the truth
take a
listen go ahead fall I would really like
to just Comfort Shaz we are saving your
children we are we're saving your
children from you pedophile Republican
[__] yes so there well um and
he also says look here Shaz says the the
alphabet mob is in Dr Danny children
okay Shaz pay attention here because
your little Nazi Hansen she's got some
background here her and her husband take
a look children seeing images that they
could not unsee was why the Franklin
Alderman said she Tri to block a Pride
Celebration at a Franklin Park saying in
a podcast interview it was a question of
basic morality yet where was her
morality during Chicago's 2008 Pride
Parade before The Hansons moved to
Tennessee at the time Tom Hansen was
running a republican campaign for
Congress and organizers agreed to let
him in he told the local lgbtq newspaper
quote so it just came to me I said maybe
I'll wear an American flag Speedo and my
wife said if you do that I'll hold you
to it okay so um Gabriel Hansen's
husband um decided to go to a pride
parade to participate in the pride
parade so he could drum up some support
from the lgbtq community and the way he
did that Texas Paul is he dressed up and
you as you see here in an American flag
Speedo uh to go to that Pride event uh
and Gabriel Hansen decided she was going
to hold him to it so that way to make
sure that he would go that he would go
um and
and oh my god listen projection and
confession is the absolute [__] is
the absolute emo of all these
Republicans whether you're Trump
supporter Dan Santa supporter Gabriel
Hansen supporter just like you Shaz you
are projecting like a son of a [__]
here in the Facebook chat and I hope I
hope Facebook keeps you out of the U the
children's groups here on Facebook but
here's here's here's John Oliver listen
to what he calls Gabriel Hansen's
husband magnificent so just to recap
snatched Elmo irreparably harmful to
Children Star Spangled ball bag here
that's apparently completely fine with
her also and I'm not here to Poli anyone
else's drag but is he
tucked could could could just have been
cold it was June
though
Star Spangled ball bag ball bag oh my
God okay not
only not only brilliant right not only
are they Nazis but they're ningo Nazis
they're ningo Nazis I've been calling
them ningo Nazis for quite some time now
Texas Paul probably for almost three
goddamn years I've been calling them n
poop Nazis um and I think I appreciate
Tennessee holler pointing out um the
fact that Phil Williamson or Phil
Williams excuse me Phil Williams is a
badass by pointing out this John Oliver
clip but I also I also want to thank
Tennessee holler and John Oliver for
pointing out this morning to me that
Gabriel Hansen's husband's nickname is
the Star Spangled ball bag ball bag now
we we want to laugh at this right but to
some degree this is not funny this isn't
funny at all and the reason why is
because Gabriel Hansen is trying to
become a maral candidate she's an
alderman now she's trying to become an
aial candidate uh to uh oppress her
community members and to to try to make
sure her community members do not feel
welcome not only she doing that by by
using her power as an elected official
she's doing that by having Nazis escort
around to intimidate lgbtq people when
she herself and her husband have
participated have participated in lgbtq
marches and events before to try to drum
up votes for themselves as Republicans
it really is is it really is [__]
gross and for anyone to believe that
this [__] idiot is anything but a
dumb Nazi then you just aren't seeing
what actually it is and I know some
people are saying about the volume on
the clips I I I trying with the volume
on the clips but you can do about that
sometimes there's nothing I can do about
it it's just the volume that I get off
the platform that I'm getting them on um
so and I try to turn them up as much go
please you know I mean I would really
like to see dapperness come back but on
a side note there no man over the age of
25 no matter how much time you spend in
the gym and how good-looking you think
you are no man over the age of 25 years
old should wear a freaking banana
hammock is that is that a challenge is
that a challenge because I feel like I
feel like you're challenging me I feel
like you're challenging me right now
Texas Paul no I am I am in total
disagreeance with you on this I agree
with you on most things but today I've
disagreed on a few things this one in
particular is where I'm going to
disagree with you I think anyone out
there who wants to wear a [__] Speedo
should be able to wear a Speedo and not
be judged by Texas Paul now whether you
look good whether you look good in a
speeder or not that may be you know an
objective truth or lie but hey if you
want to wear a Speedo wear a [__]
Speedo you know what I mean you know
what I
mean no you don't think so you don't
think
so as you put it banana banana hammock
now I don't I don't know thought a
banana hammock was a thong for a dude or
Speedo has a full ass on it doesn't it
doesn't it Speedo have a full ass on it
look B like a banana hammock to me I
mean that dude didn't you know I mean
had the little thin lines to go up
looked like his ass was eating that
thing but you know oh okay well you know
hey to eat its own if you if you want to
wear underwear or or swimwear out in
public that that your ass eats the thing
you know what whatever you want to do
I'm I'm all for it I'm I'm for um people
um not um tabooing sexuality speaking
speaking of thongs uh going over like a
wet fart and a white thong speaking of
thongs um did you see rfk's launch of
his independent campaign oh my God you
talk about going over like a w you talk
about going over like a wet fart and a
white thong holy [__] this is the
funniest [__] I've seen in a while it's
hilarious H go ahead you got to tell
people this was coordinated this was
their best effort folks this was
choreographed this was them kicking off
a presidential campaign man it's true
it's true it's hilarious uh uh I can't I
can't help it Shaz is still around Shaz
is still trolling I I love you buddy
keep keep engaging keep putting comments
that way my audience pushes back on you
like they do because they're great at it
it gets engagement on my page which
brings more followers which means more
idiots like you see this [__] and I know
Ronda santis is probably sent you here
in the campaign to sent you here to see
what I'm saying about him but Shaz you
say RFK is a patriot now RFK was a
patriot you are correct Robert F Kennedy
was a patriot he was the Attorney
General he ran for president he was
assassinated um but RFK Jr is a dumb
[__] his son is a dumb
[__] so I don't know if you
meant junior or not maybe you meant JFK
junr I'm not really sure shees with the
two brain cells you got left to rub
together but let's see let's watch let
watch RFK Jr absolutely listen Texas
Paul I have not seen a campaign launch
like this oh my God I have not seen a
campaign launch like this since Ronda
santis I tell you what I just haven't
seen an entry into the
race like this his voice man his voice
is like being eared constantly it's just
ah I can't and Shaz needs to keep
promoting RFK he really does yeah
because RFA RF K is predicted to take
four to 5% of of right-wing voters in
the next election so yeah go RFK let me
let me tell you a little bit about about
how Ronda santis has laid laid the
groundwork for RFK to run an independent
campaign and for uh uh [__] like
Shaz to support RFK instead of trump and
this is great and really honestly
democrats should not be as scared of
this um they should they should run with
this they should let RFK honestly we
should be sending RFK our money for him
to run to [__] get Trump DRS and the
reason why is because dumb [__] like
like Shaz here he really believes he
really believes that that RFK Jr is
right on vaccines that's why Shaz and
the reason why is because Shaz is
deluded by Ronda Santos because he
thinks Ronda santz is right on vaccines
which he was for the vaccine he got the
[__] vaccine he's Ved um but they
tried what happened was is when Ronda
santz first launched his campaign what
they tried to do was go back to um March
April and May of 2020 and relit mitigate
the difference between Ronda santz and
Donald Trump then and the reason why is
because Ronda santz knew that he
couldn't give a fullon assault to the
cult leader right he had to get people
to think about why the cult leader
wasn't actually the cult leader right
that's what he had to do so what he what
the Ronda santz campaign has done for
RFK Jr and really for us Democrats here
um in in this independent run is they
they got they they funded RFK Jr to go
all over the Internet and they oted this
idiot all over the to right- wiers H to
get right- wiers to say that Joe Biden
needs an opponent now what they didn't
count on is RFK Jr is a very egotistical
dumb [__] and that he would
believe his own [__] because what
happened was is when RFK actually went
out there and and gathered up a bunch of
Internet incels like Shaz here who
believe all kinds of [__] lies and
says that RFK Jr is a patriot you know
and all that [__] what the rightwing
didn't count on is that RFK would go
well hey maybe I can maybe I can win the
the right-wing did not think that RFK
would leave the Democratic party and did
not think that he thought that he would
win which is uh you know a signal of the
rightwing how stupid they really truly
are they're really they're they don't
future proof anything when they do these
things but watch this here as RFK Jr
tries to launch his campaign this is
[__]
hilarious but the good news is is that
people well maybe like yourselves are
finally fed
up
something they got the sign in front of
the camera it's hilarious keep going yep
oh I got another video I'm gonna show
you but this is this is his pitch to
these people listen thing is stirring at
us that says it doesn't have to be this
way people stop me everywhere at
airports at hotels and malls on the
street and they remind me that this
country is ready for a history-making
change they're ready they are ready to
reclaim their freedom their
independence
and saw
that and that's why I'm here
today myself an independent
candidate
and there's a couple dozen people there
cheering for him that's the hilarious
part but watch watch when he gets into
his policy points see if you can point
out what his policies are if he has
[Music]
any you know typically in one of these
things Tony you instruct people how high
they can lift their signs I mean this is
typically how they're choreographed you
you know when the crowd this is a
choreograph crowd you point out the
cameras are there the cameras are there
no signs above you know above your head
you know don't do that we'll have cues
for you to cheer then you raise them up
and then you bring them back down I mean
you you communicate with your audience
how to do this this is look at this
[__] idiot in the front man with the
glass is
on holding the sign in front of the
camera like and literally they don't
even know it they don't have a they
don't have a comm's person because what
you normally have on a on on a c a real
campaign a real one is that you would
actually have a comm's person that's
watching the monitor to make sure that
that monitor it nothing's going wrong in
the Monitor and if it was like this guy
oning the sign security would go and ask
him to hold his sign down or get him to
[__] move so that way his sign is not
blocking I don't know the candidate but
I'm going to show you a clip here in a
little bit of how it started but this is
how it's going watch this that's not all
I'm here to join you in making a new
Declaration of Independence for our
entire nation oh you hear that you hear
that John John Robert F Kennedy I almost
said John F Kennedy Jr I mean most these
people think that John F Kennedy Jr is
still alive but Robert Robert F Kennedy
Jr here is going to get rid of our
Declaration of Independence in Texas
Paul I wonder if he's going to get rid
of our con stition too I don't know
maybe he will maybe he won't let's
listen I got a question
yeah our Declaration of Independence
what is he like gonna give us back to
freaking England I I don't know I don't
know what he means I I I I know I know
he's trying to speak in in 40,000 foot
levels because he really can't get down
into the weeds of what his politics are
the reason and and folks let me tell you
something the reason why RFK is going to
break up the Trump vote is because RFK
is going to just keep spewing anti-back
[__] because it's the only thing that he
can do to and attract an electorate
because the [__] that he's about to say
he can't attract an electorate and the
reason why is because all the science
community that RFK um for years and
years and decades has actually been a a
climate change activist in has abandoned
him and the reason why is because RFK
has abandoned the idea of science um and
and listen to what he says listen to the
people he wants to go after here this is
[__] wild stuff listen from the
corporations that have hijacked our
[Music]
[Applause]
government and we declare independence
from Wall Street from Big Tech from Big
Pharma from Big Egg on the military
contractors and their
[Music]
[Applause]
lobbyists and we declare
independence from the mercenary
media that is here to the guy with the
sign again ify all of the corporate
orthodoxies from their advertisers and
to urge us to hate our neighbors and to
fear our
[Applause]
friends and we declare independence from
the cynical Elites who betray our
H he literally cynical Elites really RFK
Jr are you [__] kidding me you're
last name is Kennedy
[__] this declare independence so a
cynical Elite is going to come along and
declare uh America's independence from
cynical Elites are you [__] [__]
me okay keep going friend and who
amplifier
divisions oh really Amplified divisions
H and finally we declare independence
yeah from the two political parties
there it
is
have you ever met the [__] Texas
Paul that's like oh both sides are bad
both sides are horrible and then you're
like well who would you vote for and
you're like well I'd probably vote for
Trump have you ever met that
[__] yeah you ever met that
[__] freaking time guess who
that motherfucker's gonna vote for if
RFK is on the ballot in the general
election in their state guess who
they're gonna vote for because he's
gonna be saying that [__] over and over
and over again and he's going to give
them their little antib backs their
little antix victim [__] that they speak
all that [__] oh man it's going to be
great and I think you're 4% that you
said because you said you think they'll
pull about 4% of Maga vote I actually
think he'll pull 12 to 15% of Maga vote
and I hope he does I hope he [__]
does because I was talking to a friend
of mine um who said that he hopes that
he gets to vote for someone other than
Trump and Biden and he hopes that it
might be RFK Jr or maybe VC would run an
independent campaign and I sent him um
this V not this video but actually I did
s in this video but I want to show you a
different video that also happened right
before his speech here um but to show
you how ridiculous RFK Jr really truly
is um but the thing is is
that it's people who say both sides that
are gonna vote for Trump because they're
not saying both sides because they're
making an argument about both sides
that's not what they're doing they have
to make that argument because that it's
the same argument that or it's the same
[__] that the house is trying to do by
pretending to impeach Joe Biden because
they're trying to get voters out there
to say well you know Trump is bad Trump
is a criminal but Joe Biden is too so
I'll vote Trump right so they're trying
they got to give him a [__] reason
now RFK Jr enters in the mix because the
rightwing didn't count on him believing
his own [__] and now now he's gonna
pull votes he's gonna pull the disantis
vote the people that are out there like
Shaz have [__] you know slob um
meatballs knob or or or de boogers knob
whichever nickname that you want to use
um they're going to vote for RFK Jr
because Dan Santa is definitely a't
going to be on the ballot in the general
election go ahead this is the opening of
his campaign right here this Drone
footage was supposed to be this is
hilarious the opening of his
presidential campaign right well now now
the other thing too if you noticed in
the last clip he was speaking into
microphones and he had a mic on his face
right now my best guess for this is
they're going to produce a campaign
video so there's going to be like a
Sizzle reel right there's going to be a
Sizzle reel of RFK like before it where
he's off stage and he gets up on stage
and like you said they're gonna have the
Drone footage but they wanted him to be
mik the entire time right the problem is
is they put that mic into the feed um
not not into its own feed to record it
so that they had it for the sizzle reel
watch this as RFK kind of I don't know
he's upside down in back backwards here
[Applause]
apparently I need my
speech you I need my speech you can't
read
anything
yeah it's it's upside down
down turn it over
up couldn't happened to a better guy let
me tell you Texas Paul oh my
God oh my God so that's that's how it
kicked off yesterday you know what's
funny about this is his wife is Cheryl
hin she's an actor um on Kirby Your
Enthusiasm and talk about the perfect
Kirby Your Enthusiasm moment right there
from [__] RFK J that that listen
normally when you have a real campaign
not only is there comms directors that
are watching the monitor to make sure
some dip [__] ain't holding up the sign
in front of the P the news pool camera
feed so that so that you can not see the
candidate there's also someone that
makes sure the teleprompter isn't
projecting up sign
down oh my [__] god even Trump man go
ahead go ahead he has the The Walking
scab Steve Bannon and Roger Stone
screwed up so bad when they introduced
him into the to the right-wing MAA
bloodstream this guy's been a grifter
forever you know his grift has always
been uh to you know like Jim Carrey you
know Jim Carrey The the actor he got
into him about the antiva [__] and Jim
Carrey believes craziness now and sends
Robert Kennedy money I mean he has
really been tapping into this antiac
[__] forever and then they put him into
the MAA bloodstream dude MH and he ain't
letting go no he is not letting go he's
a leech that has latched on to Maga and
he is staying there baby forever he's
GNA be there because he's figured out
that he could siphon money from your
crazy Papa your your crazy uncle and and
yeah man I love it dude and I love Shaz
he's been in the comments he's a good
Democratic candidate Democrats are
trying to silence R Jr and I'm laugh
[__] Democrat dud baby he's yours
he's your Dem let
go he ain't letting go he's got your
nuts forever dude here's his wife Cheryl
Hines um trying to give her best speech
it's [__] wild that she's an actor
and I I I I'm guessing that the
telepromter was upside down at this
point too that she didn't know what the
[__] to say so I don't know why they
ended up having it upside down when he
got on stage but watch this this is
weird [__] when when she's talking watch
this so yeah Bobby yeah has stood up for
the little guy for the average person
who's just trying to make a living he's
been doing that all his life no he
hasn't no he hasn't actually no he
hasn't he's been ping around with Elites
he's been rubbing elbows with Democratic
Elites like George Soros shz Shaz if
it's the Democrat that you want
guess guess what [__] Robert F
Kennedy Jr Bobby Kennedy was his whole
life he was rubbing elbows with all
those liberal Elites that you talk about
like George Soros and [__] taking money
from him to go give speeches on climate
change you dumb son of a [__] you you
people Chaz you are a dumb [__]
you I mean keep coming back my friend
and keep commenting I can't wait over
the coming weeks and months to pull up
your comments you are a dumb
[__] Shaz keep supporting RFK Jr
man please at it good work buddy good
work little man good good job little
trooper right get on the internet and
support RFK Jr the best you can the best
you can him and his his weird ass wife
what the [__] was that what did you I
thought the same thing when I saw that I
was like surely this is surely this is
that the the prompter is upside down for
her too because some people could
actually read upside down I actually can
read upside down and the reason why not
very well but I can the reason why it's
because I'm dyslexic so I I've had to
like train myself to follow lines my
whole life when I'm reading so like one
of my biggest fears and I I don't know
if the audience knows this or not is to
read out loud to people and I do it
every [__] day here on the show it's
a huge fear of mine because I'm I'm not
good at reading I'm I'm very dyslexic
and I I'm the kind of dyslexic that I
lose the line like the line that I'm on
that's that's that's the dyslexic that I
am so what I've had to do is train
myself so that's why I can read upside
down the reason why is because I can
follow I've trained myself to where I
can follow the line if that if that make
does that make sense does that make
sense maybe maybe that sounds like
foreign language but a lot of people are
asking what the hell's wrong with his
voice he's got he's got a disease it's
called spasmodic dysphonia it causes
what are called familiar TM familial
trimmers um same kind of thing that
happened with Katherine Hepburn remember
when she got really older you could
barely understand
her when she talk it's the muscles on
your larynx spasm when you speak that's
why he sounds so freaking weird it's
like being ear raped man and and I'm not
picking on people that that that that
have spasmo spasmodic dysphoria I'm just
suggesting you probably shouldn't run
for
president if you can't talk I me I mean
you know what I want him to run for
president so go Shaz go RFK Jr because
honestly this is going to peel off a lot
of votes a lot a lot a lot of vot votes
um from from Donald Trump not not Joe
Biden i' hate to I hate to be one I
showed this clip yesterday but I want to
show it again I don't know if you caught
this Texas ball um now I kind of set it
up yesterday and the audience uh I don't
know if they caught on to me but they'll
catch on to me today this guy here in
the back have you seen this clip of this
old okay so this old wrink we're gonna
show it to texasball audience don't say
in the chat anything keep your keep your
[__] fingers still I'm going to [__]
with Texas Pawn here okay all right so
this old wrinkly ball sack here in the
back they're in Pennsylvania which you
know Pennsylvania's kind of purple right
Texas Paul am I right on that I do okay
now this old dude back here if you seen
this old dude at Walmart he'd probably
walk up you say yeah that Joe Biden he's
he's not doing anything good for our
country wouldn't that guy probably walk
up to you in Walmart and say that I mean
he looks like he's got an old white
wrinkly ball sack I think he'd probably
say that to you wouldn't he Texas Paul
you met these guys you met these guys
out in the b haven't you well anybody
that looks even remotely close to me
with gray hair I automatically assume
because you know they're probably MAA
they probably are I well I mean let's
find out let's see what this
Pennsylvania voter here what this
wrinkly old ball sack has to say and
then you can tell me what you think if
the country's swinging towards Trump or
not is there any chance you would stay
at home on Election Day no I I love
American democracy too much heard but
Biden and Trump if it's a Biden and
Trump race
then I would vote for Biden even if he
was
dead
heard I didn't see the clip I heard the
audio of oh my God such a good great
that's such a good clip he's like yeah
had vote for Joe Biden even if he was
dead I don't give a I don't vote for a
corpse over Donald Trump amen I've said
it over and over again if Joe Biden died
today i' SLA some sunglasses on him and
we'd weaken and Bernie his ass all the
way to the election and win anyways B
when win anyways oh man it's so great
it's so great now you know there again
there is a contrast there is a contrast
with h you know people that actually
look like this here's another clip from
from waterl Iowa I showed the the
audience a clip of the lady saying and I
think I believe it was this lady right
here um that that said that she believes
that Trump was sent by God to save
America or some [__] but watch this is
this is right after that clip or right
before that clip some it's on that war
room it's on Trader TV News Network here
but they're in waterl Iowa outside of a
outside of a a middle school gymnasium
where Trump filled halfway um the middle
school gymn I mean there was more people
that showed up for the girls basketball
game um the next day but you know Trump
supporters really thought that he had a
lot of support and you're going to see
in this clip if I fast forward a little
bit here look at this guy right there
look at that guy right there that kind
of looks familiar just looks like the
guy in the L clip just with a beard
right but let's listen to what these
people what they care about with the
issues let's listen what do you guys
want to hear from president Trump yeah
what's the number one issue what is it
top issue top issue top issue top issue
top yeah what do you guys want the top
issue that's what they want to hear from
Trump Texas ball the top issue I wonder
if these people were paid on Craigslist
show up at this [__] what do you
think when they're like nope I don't
want to be on camera I don't want to be
on camera don't put me on I think yeah
they're the typical MAA dumbass they
don't know what's going on they don't
know what they support until they're
told they don't give a [__] all they're
there for is to talk [__] about
Democrats and feel good about how
special they are because you know
they're they're MAA and they're better
than everybody else I mean it's just a't
[__] man the the these MAA voters
you know you were talking about the
Palestinians earlier and comparing
comparing Republicans to Hamas it's
exactly that it's exactly that it's EXA
spread the word go spread the word and
tell them I tell them I said so that's
that's what that old [__] don't give a
damn about anything or anyone it's just
he's that's his cult that's his group
right there that that that's what he
wants to hear you know I mean right well
speaking of cult and I I I showed that
clip and I have another clip that I
forgot to show yesterday I really didn't
have time of Nancy mace about Jim Jordan
uh being the Speaker of the House Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan um here's
Nancy mace I don't know she hadn't heard
of Jim Jordan before she wants him to be
speaker but she's never heard of him
before apparently
let's listen to this I know you've been
outspoken about um defending victims of
sexual assault due the past allegations
against Jim Jordan that he turned a
blind eye to sexual abuse give you any
reservations I yeah I'm not a familiar
or aware with that I he's not indicted
on anything that I'm aware of and so I
don't oh so now now the bar for Nancy
Ma's indictment did you hear that did
you hear that Texas Paul the bar for
indictment now she should know that a
guy who endorsed Jim Jordan the former
president of United States has indicted
on 91 different charges in four
different jurisdictions I wonder if that
indictment makes a difference to her I
wonder if Nancy I wonder if Nancy Bon is
just full of [__] [__] here watch
this this is great this is great now
Brennan doesn't really press her the way
she should the Press just is not good at
this at all but let let's watch don't I
don't know anything I can't speak to
that but I will
say
a very yeah I don't I don't know
anything and I I don't know anything
about that what I do know is that I've
been a very strong voice for she doesn't
know anything about Ohio State
apparently she has no clue no clue who
Jim Jordan is she he's just a coffee boy
in the in the Senate why why is she on
my screen I right why why are you
here information right what the [__] and
and Brendan you know I keep saying this
and I know people won't like that I'm
attacking Brenan here but she's so
[__] weak she can't go wait a second
wait a second your she can't say what I
just [__] said said wait a second
you're saying that you know no none of
these allegations about Jim Jordan and
Ohio State University whether they're
true or false you have never heard of
these allegations so you don't know who
Jim Jordan is why are you pimping that
Jim Jordan should be the speaker of the
house if you have if you haven't looked
into what the allegations against Jim
Jordan and by the way if indictment is
the [__] bar here why are are you
supporting Jim Jordan who is [__]
endorsed by a 91 indicted felon in four
different jurisdictions two of them are
[__] election interference why are
you even supporting Jim Jordan Brenan
can't go that far because Brennan has
corporate sponsors and they would slash
out at her if she would be hard on
Republicans oh boy imagine if Nancy mace
got a real [__] question that she'd
have to answer women I've talked to Jim
Jordan and Steve sque about that I've
been a very strong advocate for rape
victims as you mentioned earlier the
Judiciary Committee as with him as
chairman recently passed a rape kit bill
that Barbara Lee and I are working on
and those are the facts and the data
that I have to work with and I've had a
very positive experience with him in
that regard oh well you know Jim Jordan
looked the other way when when men were
being raped in the shower not women so
Nancy mace doesn't know anything about
that nothing about that she knows
nothing about that because she only
cares about if Jim Jordan were to rape
women apparently not if he would look
away when when men were being sexually
assaulted by members of the staff at
Ohio State and then try to cover it up
so no one found out that he was
capitulating to a bunch of [__] skis
bag sexual assaulters oops I just wanted
to play that clip I'm really I wanted to
get that no it's I'm glad you did man
because it it just shows the freaking
hypocrisy uh you know that that they
don't really give a [__] they don't care
about kids they don't care about
students they don't care about young
people they don't care about anybody
uh all they all they you know it's it's
just our cult our team our anything you
ask him a question about something that
everybody knows about every knows about
everybody knows about the OSU Scandal
everybody knows that that Jim Jordan
tried to suborn perjury from one of the
athletes so he wouldn't
testify um you know it's just one
but they just can't
I I just it's so frustrating man I it's
so damn frustrating that the corporate
media just lets this happen Tony you
know come on one of our shows and get
your balls grabbed you know because you
know man Nancy ma is a set of balls in
there somewhere I mean she
just I mean do you think she wears do
you think she wears a star spangled
Speedo you think she yeah I'm telling
you something ain't right about that
girl huh something ain't right about
that I usually we we we go to Gabe
Sanchez on Tuesday but Gabe Sanchez is
out of power he does not have power
where he's at in his studio right now so
I don't know if he's GNA do his show
later on today um but I'm trying to get
enough time here to try to go to him um
so I'm kind of stalling but that and the
reason why I'm gonna stall here is to
show you this uh statement here this is
from you looking that up yeah go ahead
why are you looking that up um you know
you were talking about the the you know
doxing people you get threats I know I
youve posted them before you get threats
I I don't I don't get threats I don't
get threats as many as most because they
they think I'm I they think I'm one of
them or some [__] it's weird they don't
want to send me death threats because
you know I I I sound like one of them I
guess I don't know I don't get as many
deaths as most you know I put my PO Box
on my on my web page you know people
send me [__] this that and the other and
I do a show about I live 10 15 minutes
from three headquarters according to the
anti-deformation Le it there are three
headquarters for white supremacist
organizations right in this area man and
I did a show on it outed him this that
and the other what what do you think I
got in my po.
box just they let me know that I don't
know a letter when did when did they
send you a Rebel Rebel Pride that's they
sent
you so so does that mean they're so that
does that mean they're LGBT rebel I
don't know a Confederate LGB T Rebel is
that what I don't know it's [__]
weird stuff I mean I got people send me
coffee I get people send me [__] all the
damn time but I have never had one of
these as soon as I did that show man I
did yeah I guess they doxed me about a
year ago on the internet they decided to
dox me and and I had to I my phone like
I have to set my phone to where if it's
an unknown number it doesn't ring
through because every once in a while
they get a hold of the video and they
they want to call me and [__] they want
to text text me some weird [__] and you
know so they they and they signed me up
for a bunch of [__] like like a spam
email things but speaking of spam emails
that's kind of what Robert F Kennedy Jr
is a spam email but here's a statement
from the Kennedy family I don't mean to
jump back to this but I'm trying to wait
to see if Gabe Sanchez I love this I'm
glad you're doing it man yeah I'm glad
you're showing this man here's here's
the Kennedy family here's how they feel
about um RFK Jr so Shaz if you're
listening this is how the Kennedy family
the actual Democrats and the family feel
about this [__] um it says the
decision of our brother Bobby to run as
a third party candid against Joe Biden
is dangerous to our country Bobby might
share the same name as our father but he
does not share the same values Vision or
judgment you hear that he's not a
Democrat Shez or at least he's not their
kind of democrat today's announcement is
deeply stading for us we denounced his
candidacy and believe it to be perilous
for our country even his brothers and
sisters hate that
[__]
I can't stop laughing honestly I don't
want Bobby to drop out and I think
they're dead wrong I actually think that
Bobby Kennedy Bobby or Bobby Kennedy's
cesy helps Joe Biden
because dumb [__] like Shaz is gonna go
vote for him um did this happened I mean
this is happened always keeps happening
to Republicans there was a Senator
running not too long ago same thing man
they their families come out don't vote
for this [__] don't vote for we
know him don't don't vote for this
[__] I mean it's just it always
happens to these right- Wingers man it
just I mean cracks me the hell up it
really does um you know I I wanna I wna
uh leave on one more Point U Back to
what's going on overseas in Israel Gabe
Sanchez still does not have power now
hang on a second um let me see if he
will you do a show later when you do let
see what he says um
and it looks like it looks like that he
does not have power today no he said not
today so Gabe Sanchez will not be doing
what was that live today he'll probably
be back tomorrow but I want to show you
something that um Rachel bofer um
actually posted here and this is
incredible now for anyone out there
saying that the United States and Joe
Biden does not support Israel and is not
giving them support you do not know what
the Iron Dome is um the Iron Dome is
what protects Israeli citizens from
Rockets coming from Gaza uh from Hamas
which are funded by Iran and Putin um if
you're not keeping track um but here is
a picture of the Iron Dome Rachel bofer
um actually posted this now the Iron
Dome is a defense system and what the
Iron Dome does is it deploys um
anti-missile rockets that um deploy to
stop these rockets in midair um and it
is something else to see they were
showing this on I wasn't watching MSNBC
this morning I listen to it I don't
watch it um I was watching it because I
wanted to listen to the um or I was
listening to it because I wanted to
listen to the Ronda santis interview I
wanted to see if they were going to push
back on him at all and I was sorely
disappointed um but they were showing
Richard
angle uh in in Israel and they were at
that point uh live they were sending uh
rocket uh rocket uh attacks on Israel
and the Iron Dome was working so it was
uh and again here's a picture of the
Iron Dome and this is thanks to the
United States so anyone who has any
question if the United States supports
Israel at all um this this should be
your evidence right here is that they
absolutely support Israel they always
have even even people who want to call
like Jimmy Carter an anti-semite because
Jimmy Carter really felt the need to
give humanitarian relief to Palestinians
uh in Gaza and the Gaza Strip and the
West Bank but here here you see
here you see the U the defense system of
the Iron Dome stopping those Rockets
from just piling on top of Israel as
Hamas continues their attacks on Israel
and that is what it is it's attacks on
Israel it won't last very long folks
because they Israel is going to cut them
off from their water and their diesel
Supply they need diesel to maintain
their power and because Israel will cut
them off this this assault will not last
much longer maybe in the days to come
there'll be a there'll be some sort of
uh um um no fire agreement what do they
call it Texas Paul I'm missing it
ceasefire but you know what man in the
in in the early assault they did
actually overwhelm the Iron Dome uh that
Tech that technology that training came
out of Russia right it's a very
sophisticated air defense system
defeating it in the with the early
attacks they that came out of Russia the
the air Commando the the Airborne
Commando training was done with the uh
Iran uh Iranian guard uh also the
amphibious Landing attacks was training
done with the Iranians uh this was
wholly supported by Putin 100% the the
technology required the strategy
required to defeat the Iron Dome system
in the early hours of the attack came
straight out of Russia that is something
that even Iran isn't capable of I mean
this is really Dan on Dan on um YouTube
here is claiming Vagner helped I don't
know if that's true or not we'd have to
check that but Vagner group you know the
Vagner group was the ones who marched
towards Moscow um to to un unseat Putin
and unseat the Putin government but they
were unsuccessful and their leader
prosan um ended up in a plane crash huh
that's kind of that's something else
isn't it huh if I could implore people
one just one thing okay Israel didn't
pick this battlefield Hamas did Hamas
chose to go to war with Israel and they
knew the war would be in
Gaza so the next few days the corporate
media is going to flood your Airwaves
with these poor gazin that are hurt and
this that and the other please always
remember Hamas chose this battlefield
the IDF has done everything they can to
allow civilians to get out of the way
they've created safe zones
they've even so far as to risk war with
Egypt to open up border crossings so
that people can flee this is not both
sides it is not both sides the other
thing I want to point out about um
picking the battlefield because it's
important to note that even though the
IDF is because a lot of people will say
this is that it is overcrowded and there
is nowhere to flee Hamas knows that
Hamas knows that there's not many places
to flee Hamas knows that there's going
to be civilian casualties it is it is by
Design to do that and the reason why
they designed to do that is to [__]
propagate the Palestinians that Hamas is
their Defender and Israel is the enemy
that is the entire [__] point that is
the entire point it's again in this
country Hamas is Maga it is Maga so when
you see dumb sheep saying dumb stupid
[__] and they believe crazy stuff like
like Shaz believes it's because they're
being at to be Maga just like the
Palestinian people are being propagated
to be part of Hamas or believe that
Hamas is their Defender and that the
enemy is Israel when really their enemy
is the propaganda that they're being fed
into their [__] brain the lies that
they're being told that is always your
[__] enemy is lies it is always your
enemy is the [__] lies and um U
someone says here Sundancer said here on
on YouTube Maga jihadist yeah they are
MAA jihadist it's and and and Hamas in
in Gaza is being jihadist and they're
putting they're using intentionally the
Palestinian people and convincing them
to be their shield and convincing them
that oh man there's just nothing we can
do we just we're being attacked and
again it's the provocation of Hamas that
has led to this attack in Gaza they
you're right Texas Paul they have chosen
this Battleground and they have chosen
the Battleground strategically so they
can propagate the Palestinian people to
convince them that Hamas is their
protector and Israel is the enemy that
is the [__] intent that is why Putin
is funding this that's why Iran is
funding this because this chaos helps
them keep propagating [__] to their
[__] their [__] troop it's the
same [__] it's the same [__] go ahead
big step fan asked in in the chat Egypt
isn't letting them in no no they AR
never allowed the Palestinians Egypt
defends the Border pretty heavily
against Palestinians coming across their
side now Egypt Egypt it's probably
pretty porous the other way when Egypt
gets money for arms to go across the
border I'm sure um to from Iran to to to
get into the hands of Hamas um but again
this is all the chaos this is all the
chaos that they want they want this
chaos they want this chaos and the chaos
agents around the world are loving this
it is the reason why Republicans are
having a tough footing here this country
is because they have the same chaos
going inside their party it's the same
exact chaos that they have promoted and
it's going to continue this this stuff
all around the world but again this
battle in Gaza will um there will be a
ceasefire as soon as you get um as soon
as as soon as we get in a situation
where Gaza City has been cut off from
Diesel and water um there will be a
ceasefire because they won't have a
choice um because Gaza City is in open
air prison and and again oh go ahead
they've already cut it off Tony they
already they've already cut it off I
know they're only they've only got like
two or three days they only got like two
or three days the apologists are saying
oh terrible Israel is is is hurting the
Palestinians again they're cutting off
their water it's a freaking war zone
Tony of course they are that's what you
do in war zones you cut off all
facilities and you invade that is a war
and Israel didn't start this one here's
here's the other thing I'll give you
another example um is when um when when
Russia invaded Ukraine Ukraine would cut
off resources in certain areas so Russia
would not have resources in those areas
to hold their armies there it's the same
thing that's how it works just like we
we put sanctions on Russia for invading
Ukraine we put sanctions on Iran and I
would guess if the Republicans can get
their [__] together and find a [__]
speaker then what what we'll do is we'll
actually Place more sanctions on Iran um
Financial sanctions on Iran to make it
harder to actually fund this effort for
Hamas now what what is gonna happen I I
know this is gonna happen is there's
going to be a ceasefire everything's
going to kind of go quiet for a while
and then three four five years from now
Hamas will build up their Munitions
again they will build up their ability
to fight again they will build up their
propaganda and they will build up the
hate in their country again to level an
attack against Israel and will go
through the same [__] same [__] [__]
and mainly and and I I want to tell you
that I believe this is all because of
religion it's all religion and they're
using religion to propagate to people um
this fear porn of religion to get them
to hate another [__] religion and
that's just what it is and they'll
continue to want to kill each other just
like MAA in this country uses white
Christian nationalism they use that
religion against all of us who just want
to [__] live who just want to be
Americans who just want freedom and
Liberty and want the freedom from
religion or to have our own religion but
they don't want that manga is Hamas
Hamas is maanga Maga is Hamas Hamas is
MAA remember that Texas Paul thanks for
joining me here on this Tuesday sorry we
went a little long I was seeing of Gabe
was gonna gonna cut in go to real
texas.com that's real texas.com follow
him go watch his show on Sundays and
Wednesdays tomorrow morning he'll be on
an hour before me on Wednesdays real
texas.com the link is down below in the
description don't forget to hit the like
button and follow us here on the Tony
Michaels podcast you can follow us ever
go to the Tony michaels.com that's the
Tony michaels.com you can find all the
links there if I miss your show support
today it's because I was totally
distracted by everything we'll get to it
tomorrow I promise same time same place
tomorrow thanks for joining us dexas
Paul surf sub
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
in political news no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow Tony
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
[Applause]
[Music]
I need my
speech you
you can't read anything you can't read
anything
what
yeah it's it's upside down upside
down it's upside
[Applause]
down